que au terme des derniers travaux que
nous avons consacré à la situation
spécifique dans nos territoires
ultramarins notre mission d'information
a souhaité revenir un travail plus
globale sur la situation de l'épidémie
de covile dans notre pays et sur les
perspectives à court et moyen terme
cette situation évolue très rapidement
chacun peut le constater avec la montée
de la cinquième bague et tout
dernièrement l'apparition d'un nouveau
variant préoccupant dont les
caractéristiques sont en cours
d'évaluation et dont vous ne parlerez
certainement jeu les unes des autres
cette vague a d'ores et déjà des
implications en terme de politique
sanitaire avec l'accélération du
calendrier de rappel vaccinal elle
pourrait en avoir également comme si le
cas dans certains pays voisins sur les
conditions d'accès aux lieux publics les
membres de la commission des affaires
sociales qui
entendra et je salue sa présidente
catherine de roche qui entendra la
semaine prochaine le président du
conseil scientifique scientifiques
participent également à notre réunion je
veux remercier vivement de leur présence
nos trois invités dominique costagliola
qui épidémiologistes directrice de
recherche inserm à l'institut pierre
louis des mêmes pays des murs j2ee de
santé publique et grand prix inserm 2020
félicitations professeur karine lacombe
qui est infectiologues et qui est chef
du service des maladies infectieuses à
l'hôpital saint-antoine à paris et le
professeur yazdan yazdanpanah qui est
directeur de l' agence nationale
maladies infectieuses émergentes et chef
de service des maladies infectieuses à
l'hôpital bichat et enfin membre du
conseil scientifique
donc je vais vous donner successivement
la parole à tous les trois pour vous
nous livriez de façon relativement brève
votre appréciation générale de la
situation avant que nous leur posons
certainement de très nombreuses
questions je rappelle que notre mission
d'information a publié en juillet
dernier une série de recommandations
avec nos deux rapporteurs roger
karoutchi et jean michel arnaud
ses recommandations s'intituler
stratégie vaccinale agir maintenant pour
limiter l'impact de la probable
quatrième vague à l'automne en fait
c'était pandémie nous a appris
l'humilité depuis bien longtemps
d'ailleurs et nous ont tous été surpris
par une vague qui a et estivale il ya
bien une vague à l'automne tout de même
et c'est la cinquième comme tout le
monde le sait il y avait 2 dans une
série de recommandations sur la
vaccination sur la réduction de la
circulation du virus est notamment chez
des enfants avec la rentrée scolaire on
voit que c'est une problématique
actuellement
voilà écoutez je vais vous donner la
parole sans tarder en commençant donc
par dominique costagliola
ou pardon certainement catherine de
roche veut ajouter qu'elle non
j'aimerais ajouter parce que je suis en
retard
simplement
plaisir pendant associés à ces auditions
de la mission de suivi de covile il y
aura beaucoup de questions à vous poser
manifestement parce que les données
changent tellement tellement souvent et
ce qui incite à beaucoup de prudence
dans nos conclusions parfois mais aussi
qui pose beaucoup d'interrogations pour
nos concitoyens
dominique costagliola
merci de l'habitation et merci de votre
accueil juste deux points mon propos
d'abord je suis maintenant directrice de
recherche émérite ça veut dire que je
suis retraité et donc emerich depuis le
1er septembre ça veut dire que j'ai été
autorisé à continuer mes recherches
sur l'infection à vih est sur la queue
vide et puis par ailleurs mais aurait
signalé que mille pardons dominique mais
si vous pouviez approché micro parce que
en fait notre réunion est publique c'est
à dire qu'elle est diffusée en direct
sur le site du sénat et puis d'autre
part je voudrais signaler que mes liens
d'intérêts sont en ligne sur le site des
pays santé avec une mise à jour qui
datent de 2021 donc quelque chose qui
est à chaud je voudrais aborder 4 points
le futur de l'épidémie les mesures de
contrôle la situation dans les écoles et
puis au fond quand est ce qu'on pourrait
dire que la situation est durablement ce
contrôle donc le futur de l'épidémie
j'avais prévu la semaine dernière de
dire que ça dépend des de l'apparition
de variants bon alors là ça dépend de
l'apparition de darian est pour
l'instant de micro ondes et peut-être
pas le dernier non plus alors sur ce
nouveau variant
il semble mais les informations sont pas
encore très solide qu' il puisse être
plus transmissible
heureux c'est ce qui semble être observé
pour l'instant en afrique du sud mais le
contexte est assez différent en terme de
pour personne personnes immunodéprimées
pro personne personne d'actionner donc
on peut pas trop complètement prédire ce
qui va se passer en europe et en france
on sait pas non plus s'il est associé à
des formes plus grave pour l'instant
c'est juste des bruits mais il faut
avoir un peu plus de données pour le
savoir et c'est d'autant plus compliqué
à déterminer maintenant que comme
beaucoup de gens sont vaccinés il ya peu
de données qui permettent de bien
documenter si on a des formes plus grave
alors ça pose des enjeux sur
l'efficacité des vaccins et sur le fait
de savoir s'il faudra adapter les
vaccins c'est pas certain bien sûr les
fabricants de vaccins nous disent qu'ils
travaillent à ça ils sont dans leur rôle
mais faut déjà voir si au fond les
anticorps qu'on fabrique suite à ces
vaccins sont capables ou pas de
neutraliser ce variant et ça ça va
prendre quelques semaines de le savoir
c'est un autre impact aussi sur des
traitements qui sont déjà disponibles en
accès précoce donc si en cours
d'évaluation a la chance européenne du
médicament qui sont notamment les
anticorps monoclonaux les cocktails
d'anticorps monoclonaux
puisque certains peuvent être trop
ciblées sur certaines parties de la
protéine spike sur lequel il ya
justement des mutations dans ce nouveau
variant et pourrait du coup moins bien
fonctionné donc il ya un enjeu est que
ces produits qu'on a commencé à utiliser
même si c'est pas très facile puisqu'il
fallait donner précocément il faut qu'il
soit donné à l'hôpital donc voilà il ya
un enjeu est là je ne doute pas aussi
qu' on aurait bientôt des données sur
cette situation il ya des premières
données que commence à sortir disons
dans les circuits les circuits de
professionnels il va se poser aussi la
question des médicaments
alors je reparlerai pas des médicaments
et je doute pas qu'on en parle quand
même dans la suite 2 mais est ce que est
ce que les médicaments notamment les
antiviraux on va aussi donner très
précocement qui pouvait être peut-être
d'une personnalité ce plus facile
d'utilisation parce que par voie orale
des comprimés est ce qu'ils vont marcher
finalement contre ceux contre ce nouveau
variant est bien voilà il va falloir
avoir des données y compris pour les
produits qui sont en cours d'évaluation
selon l agence européenne parce que si
ces variantes devient dominant est que
ces médicaments ne marche pas bien ça
servira à rien de dépenser de l'argent
pour les utiliser
et aussi peut-être juste une remarque
pour dire que comme le camp le virus
circule beaucoup comme c'est le cas
actuellement en france
l'utilité de fermer les frontières dans
ce contexte et modestie le virus le plus
probable c'est qu'il est déjà là il est
déjà en train de circuler avec
l'incidence que l'on a donc fermé les
frontières ne va pas aider si on avait
un taux de reproduction inférieure à 1
si on était dans une phase au virus ne
circule pas beaucoup oui ce sera
intéressant et plus que au fond
peut-être aussi d'une façon générale
fermer des frontières c'est plus les
allemands strict des gens qui arrivent
qui serait sans doute pertinent quoi
qu'il en soit
sur les mesures de contrôle je pense que
il est juste de dire que se fonder
uniquement sur une mesure biomédicale
même si elle est très efficace comme la
vaccination
on voit bien qu'avec ce virus est avec
les variants qui sont ceux qui circulent
à l'heure actuelle d'un ça suffit pas
pour espérer contrôler la situation
et on voit bien que y compris par
rapport à un nouveau variant est dans
une phase on a beaucoup de virus qui
circule ça nous met en bonne position
pour arriver à ce contrôle donc ne pas
vouloir réduire la circulation du virus
se concentrer uniquement sur la seule
chose importante c'est que l'hôpital se
passe submergées c'est pas ça qui nous
met dans la meilleure position possible
et donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment
faire de la prévention combinée c'est à
dire utiliser toutes les mesures à notre
disposition en ce sens 30 des jeunes
dans un premier temps que celles qui
sont bien sûr les moins contraignantes
pour la vie de tous les jours donc le
masque à l'intérieur puisque même y
compris dans les endroits où il ya le
passé ni terre bien entendu les vaccins
ils sont très efficaces contre les
formes graves mais sont moins efficace
contre la transmission
c'était de l'ordre de 50 % peut-être
quand on est plus à distance de la
vaccination 30% seulement c'est déjà
contributif bien sûr mais ça suffit pas
donc le masque à l'intérieur
systématiquement chaque fois que c'est
possible je dis ça parce que dans les
restaurants bien sûr il ya des moments
où on l'enlève bien évidemment
le deuxième point c'est mesure du co2
aération et une ventilation et ça c'est
dans tous les lieux clos donc ça
s'applique aux écoles au lieu de travail
ou le public c'est quelque chose qui n'a
pas été assez mis en avant ou assez
développée mais qui est vraiment un
outil je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
s'en sert pas non plus que même si c'est
un investissement il est probable qu'il
sera aussi contributif pour prévenir
d'autres agents respiratoire est au fond
une des choses sur lequel on peut
réfléchir à propos de cette épidémie de
covin c'est que jusque là on n'acceptait
pas si mal que ça le fait que la grippe
ou la bronchiolite face des passes des
dégâts et peut-être que on pourrait se
dire que finalement la des moyens
d'éviter ça aussi de façon récurrente et
que ce serait toujours cette prime enfin
troisième mesure à mon avis sur lequel
il faut jouer quand c'est possible à
nouveau c'est le télétravail le
télétravail c'est à la fois moins de
gens sur les lieux de travail donc moins
de 2 de grandes occasions de d'attraper
un virus essentiellement transmis par
les lots ça ressemble aussi moins de
gens on les transporte en commun donc
voilà moins d'endroits où on va être
beaucoup et où donc on va dans un
endroit concentré donc on va être à
risque de s'infecter
sur les écoles c'est en particulier la
situation dans les écoles élémentaires
maternelles et les crèches juillet sur
la ville dans la ville de paris la
semaine dernière mercredi et les 357
classes fermées et on n'avait que 8 qui
était collège ou lycée donc c'est
vraiment dans ce qui se passe à l'école
élémentaire et c'est assez logique
puisque c'est l'endroit où il ya la plus
grande proportion de personnes non
vaccinées parce que pour l'instant les
enfants en école élémentaire ne peuvent
pas être vaccinés la vaccination n'est
pas ouverte dans notre pays donc il me
semble que alors que les incidents sont
plus haut et en particulier donc dans
les écoles élémentaires avec des taux
qui dans certains départements dépasse
alléger le protocole des fermetures de
classes
plutôt que de passer à un niveau 3 ou 4
du protocole montre que le seul objectif
est la non fermeture des classes et non
pas le contrôle de l'épidémie et avait
le contexte de nouveaux variants je
pense que c'est donner une excellente
opportunité aux variants microns si les
plus franches mais cible est bien de se
répandre rapidement dans l'ensemble de
la population
ça me paraît une très très mauvaise idée
on sait aussi que à l'école élémentaire
ce qui est le plus efficace ce serait de
faire des tests répétés parce que les
tests et réactif
ça permet d'éviter des fermetures de
classes ou ça ne permet pas de diminuer
la transmission
mais les expérimentations qui était
prévu mais je sais par exemple qui à
paris ça commence seulement cette
semaine et seulement dans les écoles
voilà on se dit que c'est quand même pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'il faudrait faire
compte tenu des chiffres d'incidence que
j'ai rappelé et je veux rappeler aussi
que on a souvent traduit le moindre
risque chez les enfants comme si ça
voulait dire pas de risque mais en date
d'hier il y avait soixante neuf enfants
de 0 à 9 ans hospitalisée
53 de 10 à 19 ans
et depuis le début d'épidémie signale
que 13 décès jusqu'à l'âge de 19 ans il
y en a eu neuf depuis mi juin et 3 dans
les 10 derniers jours donc
ça me paraît devoir être souligné
personnellement je ne vois pas pourquoi
on doit accepter que des enfants meurent
même si c'est pas beaucoup et je ne
parle même pas des séquelles à long
terme
c'est toujours un peu une nébuleuse en
termes de quelle fraction des personnes
infectées en sont atteintes et en
particulier chez l'enfant mais tout de
même le coc vide l'on est une
problématique également mais aussi la
charge pour les enfants de ce2 peut-être
se dire qu'ils peuvent contaminer des
gens fragiles de leur entourage je ne
crois qu'il faut pas les faux pas
l'oublier non plus
et puis avec cette situation qu'on
décrit dans les écoles même si les
écoles sont ouvertes il ya quand même
beaucoup d'absences certains enfants qui
sont absents certains professeurs qui
sont absents et par conséquent une
situation scolaire qui n'est quand même
pas totalement conserver donc il me
semble que la vaccination des enfants de
5 à 11 on doit être possible maintenant
qu'elle a été approuvée par l'agent sur
les médicaments il ya un avis de la hs
disons qui dit qu'il faut l'ouvrir aux
enfants à risque avec une définition
assez large sud qu'est ce qu'ils
appellent à risque et puis aussi qui qui
dit qu'ils vont faire des consultations
avant de donner un avis parce que il ya
beaucoup de réticences mais il me semble
que ça devrait pouvoir être possible qui
ne veut pas dire de rendre obligatoire
dernier point qu'en dire que la
situation est durablement ce contrôle on
a vu à plusieurs reprises qu on nous a
dit que ça allait mieux mais on l'a vu
aussi que finalement on avait en algré
tout si peu de temps depuis mars 2020 vu
des vagues en été au printemps en hiver
et en automne alors je pense que eux il
faut attendre plusieurs mois d'une
situation calme
avant de diminuer le niveau des mesures
est de dire que ça va mieux parce que
sans ça on les diminue et chaque fois
qu'il ya un nouvel élément qui arrive au
bessat repart comme en 40 j'ose dire
parce que justement on n'est pas dans
une situation continue à se contrôler
c'est extrêmement difficile de se dire
cela évidemment mais je pense que c'est
la leçon qu'il faut tirer de ses bottes
bientôt deux ans
merci beaucoup pour ce propos très
clairs professeur gallant bana merci
beaucoup et merci pour votre invitation
donc je parle effectivement en tant
directeur de l'adresse mais aussi un
médecin hospitalier je tenais à le
préciser un chercheur est par ailleurs
vous allez précisément de concessions
tiffy et mes liens d'intérêts sans sur
le site du ministère de la santé lormont
comme dominique je voulais insister sur
quatre points
premièrement je pense que ces dernières
jours on parle beaucoup de nouveaux
variants au micro mais je pense qu'il
est avant tout important d'insister que
on est en plein face de creuse
croissance de l'épidémie en france que
cette épidémie actuellement est liée aux
variants delta et je pense que c'est
très important de regarder ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui je vais revenir au
micro ondes dominique on en parlait mais
c'est important de dire qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est en
train d'augmenter l'incidence au sein de
la population des infections
grâce à la vaccination l'augmentation
des cas d'hospitalisation est beaucoup
plus faible que les vagues précédentes
mais il y à une augmentation
on est actuellement à 700 kg/ha
journalier à peu près de
d'hospitalisation et je pense que les
modélisations montre que ça peut
augmenter et que finalement on a des
interventions à mettre en place pour
essayer de diminuer cette augmentation
et ce n'est pas trop tard et il est
important de rappeler dominique l'a dit
c'est une prévention combinée c'est
avant tout le respect que j'ai ce pas
rire sur des modélisations on voit que
même une augmentation de 10% de respect
des j'espère hier peut avoir un impact
très important sur
le devenir pour qu'on puisse passer plus
confortablement cette vague
bien sûr le rappelle on l'a dit bien sûr
toutes les mesures ventilation
télétravail qui ont été rappelés mais
vraiment il est important de rappeler à
nos citoyens que aujourd'hui il faut pas
oublier ce vague delta et que finalement
pour ne pas être dans la situation de
l'allemagne de l'autriche pour je répète
ce qui a été dit c'est que le taux de
vaccination est plus faible un conte
france finalement essayé de améliorant
même de manière discrète alors que je
pense que ça doit être fort les gestes
barrière ça me permettrait de ne pas
aller vers des mesures plus importantes
donc ça ça c'est le premier point sur le
i le variant au micron
bon
c'est très récent et vous avez commencé
par dire qu'il faut être humble je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit très simple sur ce
qu'on dit
il semblerait mais ça reste à déterminer
que ce soit plus transmis si on ne
connaît pas du tout l'impact sur la
sévérité de la maladie c'est une donnée
extrêmement important et en ce qui
concerne ce que c'est le troisième
facteur
l'impact sur l'efficacité vaccinale et
sur des traitements là non plus on
connaît pas grand chose on suspecte qu
avec autant de mutations il peut y avoir
un impact mais on n'en sait rien et je
pense que il faut dire aussi que
les interventions pour le delta
probablement sont les mêmes en dehors de
vaccination qu'on va peut-être un devoir
ajuster mais on le sait pas mais laissez
les mêmes interventions qui sont un là
pour lutter contre cette infection
d'autre part si jamais vous avez vu ce
matin il ya un cas donc
réunion qui a été d'ailleurs on a mis en
place à un réseau de séquençage avec
santé publique france et la mairesse est
en fait c'est un des laboratoires qui a
détecté ce cas là donc je pense qu'il y
aura des cas en france comme vous avez
vu il ya des quarts en europe à quelle
vitesse 1 on ne sait pas on le sait pas
quelle vitesse
sachez quand même que en afrique du sud
c'est ce virus a émergé à un moment où
la cid ans de la maladie était bas et le
virus s'était le virus delta là bas
aussi mais il y avait très peu de cas et
que l'émergence dans le cadre d'un tas
d'une région où l'incidence de delta et
très haut peut être complètement
différent nous qu'on sait pas à quel
moment ça va survenir si jamais ça
survienne le troisième élément sûr
lesquels je voulais insister c'est que
on est devant une pandémie et ça veut
dire que c'est quelque chose qui touche
le monde entière et qu'il faut que des
interventions soit et cible
l'ensemble des pays et du coup
c'est pour souligner l'importance des
interventions et notamment la couverture
vaccinale dans les pays à ressources
limitées je pense que c'est un point
important à souligner puisque on est là
devant vous
c'est un signe donné important on a les
vapes
les variations sont aussi parce qu'il ya
une circulation importante de virus et
je pense qu'on peut pas avoir dans
quelques pays du nord une couverture
vaccinale très élevé et dont d'autres
une couverture vaccinale très faible il
faut absolument qu'on réponde à cette
pandémie de manière internationale et en
saut enfin dernière chose
puisque le sujet c'était l'impact à long
terme aussi pas qu'à court terme book
dominique soulignait locaux vides long
et je voulais vous rappeler que c'est
vraiment une thématique importante qu'il
faut qu'on a qu'on essaye de mieux
comprendre parce qu'on comprenne qu'on
prend pas assez aujourd'hui et que donc
l' agence nationale de recherche contre
le sida et maladies émergentes va lancer
un appel à projets a lancé un appel à
projets avec la fondation pour la
recherche médicale pour essayer de
promouvoir la recherche autour de cette
thématique mais je voulais aussi dire
que le coc vite et ça il faut pas qu'on
oublie un impact sur les autres maladies
chroniques et je pense que c'est
important si on parle de l'impact à long
terme de dire aussi qu'il y a un impact
sur notre organisation de soins et sur
les autres maladies chroniques et
puisqu'on est à la veille de 1er
décembre journée mondiale de du sida je
voulais je vous rappeler que on assiste
alors nos malades on affine aval sont
d'ailleurs c'est dominique qui a mené
cette évanescent il pourra en parler
mieux que moi avec france laërt au sein
de l' agence en a
contenu des données qu'on a des patients
qui se connaissent et vih ont été pris
bien en charge mais par contre il ya une
baisse de dépistage de l'infection par
le vih alors on ne sait pas si c'est
parce qu'il ya une baisse des prises de
risque une best sexualité ou est ce que
c'est une baisse vraiment de l'offre de
dépistage parce que il y avait
la pandémie parce qu'il y avait les
pires ennemis mais en tout cas ça montre
combien il faut qu'on fasse attention
aussi aux autres maladies et je pense
que ce qui est en train de se passer
aussi à l'hôpital
c'est aussi un peu
des choses qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention sur l'impact de coville sur le
nom qu vite c'est extrêmement important
de l'europe de ne pas être seulement
focalisé sur locaux vie et d'avoir une
vie plus large je vous remercie monsieur
le président merci professeur lacombe
merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité à me
joindre à vous aujourd'hui donc moi je
vais me mettre en complément de tout ce
qui a été dit parce que je suis vraiment
en phase sur tous les éléments qu'on
vient de vous apporter alors moi aussi
je vous rappelle que mes liens
d'intérêts sont accessibles sur le site
du ministère dans le cadre de la dpi
donc je vais vous complétez ce qui a été
dit sur trois points d'abord l'état à
l'hôpital donc je m'exprimerai en temps
que infectiologues chef de service ici à
paris j'ai offert un point également sur
l'actualité thérapeutique parce que là
aussi on s'inscrit dans le futur et puis
justement sur le futur avec les quelques
pistes qu'il me semble devoir explorer
si on veut un jour pouvoir sortir de
cette pandémie alors tout tout tout
d'abord un point sur l'état à l'hôpital
alors il faut savoir que quand même
depuis 18 mois dans la plupart des
services de maladies infectieuses et
beaucoup de service de médecine interne
on a continué à prendre en charge des
patients affectés par la coved 19 et qu'
on est on a vu au jour le jour changer
le profil de ces patients jusqu'à la
vaccination évidemment c'était tout un
chacun alors bien sûr avec quelques
facteurs de risque supplémentaire mais
on a vu des personnes tout à fait bien
portante sans facteur de risque est
hospitalisé puis certains passaient en
réanimation est décédé depuis qu'on a
accès à la vaccination le profil a
énormément changé
80% des personnes qui arrivent à
l'hôpital avec une copine 19 ne sont pas
vaccinés et c'est celle qui sont
majoritairement les patients qui passent
en réanimation et qui décède les 20% à
peu près de patients qui sont vaccinés
qui arrivent malgré tout à l'hôpital
sont des personnes qui ont des facteurs
de risque dans particulier d'autres
comme en mobilité et surtout qu'ils ont
une deuxième dose qui est assez éloignée
en général 5 6 mois voire plus de leurs
nouvelles infections donc on voit bien
que la vaccination en tout cas dans le
contexte du delta a vraiment bien marché
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a permis et
c'est ce que l'on voit actuellement
malgré l'augmentation très brutal delà
de la transmission nous ne sommes pas
submergés nous avons plus de travail
nous avons recommencé la réunion des
cellules de crise nous commençons à
ouvrir d'autres lits mais nous ne sommes
pas submergés et j'aurais pu penser que
en faisant abstraction du possible
impact de l'eau microns on aurait pu
faire face à sète à cette quatrième
vague au niveau hospitalier donc je le
rappelle vraiment en a tendance à dire
parce qu'on a des cas de personnes
vaccinées à l'hôpital le vaccin ne
marche pas qu'en aurait-il été si on
n'avait pas eu la vaccination
évidemment là où également les choses
changent et on voit bien qu'on est coco
le col et qu'on est dans une
détérioration de la situation on
recommence à avoir quelques cas de
transmission nosocomiale donc en
particulier de familles qui viennent
visiter des patients hospitalisés qui
leur transmettent
l'infection on a également quelques
membres du personnel soignant mais pour
l'instant pas du tout de l'ampleur de ce
que l'on a pu avoir avant donc ce qui
prouve bien que la vaccination change
tout de même permet de soulager
l'hôpital en tout cas de la part
d'investissement sur la colline 19 en
revanche que l'on voit c'est qu'on est
bien sûr en tension à cause de toutes
les pathologies hivernales et en
particulier une population âgée qui est
qui a été très vulnérable
vulnérabilisés par la pandémie en ce qui
concerne l'actualité thérapeutique
on a fait d'énormes progrès en 18 mois
on a maintenant des molécules dont on a
évalué l'efficacité dont on a prouvé
l'efficacité dans le cadre d'essais
thérapeutiques de recherche bien
conduite sur le plan méthodologique mais
également sur le plan éthique qui par
exemple permettent d'améliorer la prise
en charge des personnes hospitalisées
avec des formes graves des
immunomodulateurs qui sont rentrés dans
la panoplie des traitements qui sont par
exemple recommandé par l'om s mais
également par nos instances de
recommandation mais évidemment
l'utilisation de ces traitements à
l'hôpital n'a aucun impact sur la
dynamique de l'épidémie ne permet que de
diminuer la mortalité et quand vous
regardez d'ailleurs l'évolution de la
mortalité sur ces 18 mois elle a fort
heureusement baissé ce qui prouve qu'on
a vraiment amélioré la prise en charge à
l'hôpital
à côté de ces immunomodulateurs qu'on va
utiliser à l'hôpital on a développé
toute une panoplie de médicaments
antiviraux alors on a des antiviraux qui
vont se prendre par la bouche qui sont
donc destinés à la médecine ambulatoire
est pour l'instant ces médicaments ce
d'ailleurs un d'entre eux est évalué ce
soir par là et vieillit et puis ils vont
très prochainement faire l'objet d'une
évaluation par la has on en a
actuellement deux mais d'autres qui vont
être évalués bientôt et puis d'autres
vont arriver et on espère si tenté que
l'on montre qu'effectivement ils vont
avoir un impact avec les données qui
nous devons nous est montré qu'on ne
connaît pas encore eh bien on peut
probablement envisager que la médecine
ambulatoire puisse jouer vraiment un
grand rôle dans le traitement des formes
précoces donc avant que les patients
arrivent à l'hôpital puisque le but de
ces médicaments ça va être d'éviter que
les patients arrivent à l'hôpital
évidemment qu'il décède puis à côté des
antiviraux depuis plusieurs semaines je
dirais même mois nous avons notre
disposition des anticorps monoclonaux
qui ont trois indications préférentiels
d'abord celle et donc tout chez des
personnes qui sont à risque de faire des
formes graves soit parce qu'ils ont déjà
des symptômes mais modérée soit parce
qu'ils ont été exposés à quelqu'un qui
est éprouvée malade soit en pré
exposition quand il ya un échec de
vaccination il faut dire que pour
l'instant ces anticorps monoclonaux sont
sous utilisés que c'est vrai que la
procédure pour y avoir accès et
relativement lourde est alors
qu'initialement les destinées plutôt la
médecine de ville la lourdeur de l'accès
fait que c'est plutôt à l'hôpital même
dans les structures ambulatoires mais à
l'hôpital qu'on les utilise donc il
faudrait vraiment qu'on fasse un effort
pour les rendre plus facilement
disponibles
le futur alors le futur là aussi je
dirais que de tirer de mon expérience
hospitalière je peux vous dire que les
patients qui ne sont pas vaccinés ne
sont pas des personnes ne sont pas tous
sens et c'est mal je dirais une partie
extrêmement minoritaire des personnes
vaccinées absolument contre le vaccin à
chaque fois que je fais la visite dans
mon service que je questionne ces
personnes qui arrivent non vacciner à
l'hôpital avec une copie de 19 et de
l'oxygène beaucoup me disent qu'il y à
qui l'on qu'ils ont sous-estimé bon
évidemment l'importance de l'infection
qu'ils attendaient ça c'est vrai pour
les personnes âgées que leur médecin
généraliste les contacts que c'était
parfois des personnes qui étaient en
situation de vulnérabilité
parce que il était migrants etc etc etc
on voit bien qu'on a encore un effort à
faire pour vers la les verts il y a un
problème également que la troisième dose
puisque les personnes qui ont déjà deux
doses qui arrivent à l'hôpital n'ont pas
eu cette troisième dose et effectivement
on a maintenant des données solides 1
pour montrer que
l'efficacité de la vaccination diminue
non seulement chez les personnes à
risque mais aussi chez tout le monde
d'où l'importance et j'en suis très
contente même si je pense que ça arrive
un peu tard que la troisième dose a été
étendu à tout le monde parce
qu'évidemment cette troisième dose
permet d'éviter le passage des
hospitalisations mais elle diminue aussi
la durée des symptômes et l'importance
de la réplication virale donc on peut
penser que ça diminuerait la
transmission
et je dirais qu'il faut poursuivre
l'effort de recherche extrêmement
important évidemment en termes de
traitement mais également en termes de
moyens mis sur le séquençage alors il ya
eu beaucoup de progrès qui ont été faits
en un an et demi mais on aurait envie
qu'il y ait encore plus de séquençage
fait sur tout le territoire pour pour
pouvoir identifier très rapidement les
souches qui pose problème est peut-être
si vous me le permettez je
ne reviendrai pas sur l'importance des
pays du sud on voit que le que ce soit
le delta où que ce soit l'eau mikron ce
sont des variants qui émergent dans des
populations non vaccinés ou le où le
virus se multiplie longtemps à bas bruit
ou qui sont également des pays où il ya
beaucoup de personnes immunodéprimées et
quand on regarde l'impact de la
couverture vaccinale dans le monde
entier tous les continents sauf
l'afrique soit quasi 65 % de couverture
vaccinale l'afrique 10% et
l'avenir de l'europe et du monde entier
ne se jouera pas sur celui de l'afrique
je ne reviendrai pas sur les écoles etc
parce que je pense que dominique vous en
a parlé avec des arguments assez fort
merci et puis on va revenir sur tous ces
points parce que je ne dis pas que vous
allez avoir un nombre très élevé de
questions mais merci beaucoup pour vos
propos introductif ce que je propose à
mes collègues parce que nous n'avons pas
énormément de temps vous devez nous
quitter vers 16h30 toutes les deux et
professeurs riazan pana lui restera
jusqu'à la nuit tombée mais quand même
on va on va éviter d'abuser tout de même
donc je vous propose que on va on va
poser toutes les questions à la suite
comme ça les noter vous répondez chacune
chacun à ceux à ce qui vous concerne
plus particulièrement moi je vais m'en
tenir à deux questions la première porte
sur les enfants parce que moi j'étais
quand même que dominique costagliola
nous a dit c'est en gros que il ya un
choix délibéré qui n'est pas le contrôle
de l'épidémie chez les enfants donc a
contrario
de rechercher une immunité naturelle si
je comprends bien par la circulation du
virus chez les enfants mais moi j'ai
appris qu'il ya eu trois enfants décédés
les 10 derniers jours ce qui est tout de
même je sais pas quelle était la
situation de ces enfants est ce qu'il y
avait des pathologies peu importe c'est
quand même
assez quand même un chiffre qui
marque donc dans ce contexte là enfin
comment vous expliquez que ce choix de
laisser le circuler le virus à vous
allez nous confirmer ou pas si c'est
votre votre analyse et deuxièmement vous
avez fait vous avez rappelé que l'agencé
européenne du médicament a autorisé le
vaccin pour les 5 à 12 ans qu'il est
pratiqué aux états unis sont déjà
plusieurs millions d'enfants je crois
trois ou quatre ils ont reçu
sans parler d' obligation n'est pas du
tout sur ce sujet là aujourd'hui mais
pourquoi interdire puisque de fait la
non autorisation du vaccin en france
revient à ce que les parents qui
souhaitent vacciner avec ses deux
enfants de 5 à 12 ans ne peuvent pas le
faire vacciner dont j'aurais voulu vous
nous en dise et plus ma deuxième
question porte sur la situation de
l'hôpital
karine lacombe nous a dit on aurait pu
faire face en faisant abstraction du
variant bon on aurait pu faire face et
j'aimerais que vous en disiez plus sûr
actuellement on est je crois à 1600
personnes en réanimation c'est à dire
pas loin de 30 % notre capacité de base
de réanimation quand même en france
pardon merci 1649 1749 j'étais très très
prudent donc on a passé des 30% nos
capacités de réanimation
moi j'aimerais que vous nous disiez
parce que c'est un point qui nous
inquiète évidemment c'est le risque de
saturation de l'hôpital dont on connaît
l'état du système de
soins j'ai passé la parole à mes
collègues en commençant par catherine
d'euros si vous avez des questions non
je rejoins n'ont pas vraiment de
questions
lorsqu'on avait reçu le ministre vers
ans il nous avait parlé que la france
avait acheté du mot nude
pire avis rend en quantité les derniers
j'ai lu quelques articles disant que
l'efficacité des sans doute inférieur à
ce que l'on pensait je voulais savoir si
vous êtes en phase avec cette
cette proposition est l'autre point mais
vous aviez répondu c'était sur la part
des non vaccinées dans l'hospitalisation
c'est tout qu'est roger karoutchi
oui moi une petite batterie de questions
mais très rapide 1 est ce que nous
sommes équipés en doses de vaccin si on
part sur la 3eme vaccination pour tout
le monde est ce que on va pas nous dire
dans un mois à bas on n'est pas encore
livré où il ya des problèmes comme on
l'a eu dans les mois dernier ou est-ce
que de ce côté là nous n'avons plus de
problème et les livraisons sont massives
et régulier deuxième élément est là je
m'adresse à la fois aux médecins et aux
citoyens
incontestablement
on le voit avec l'affaiblissement des
gestes barrières et et peut-être aussi
ni lassitude beaucoup de gens ont un peu
le sentiment de se dire vivement que ce
soit derrière nous et ils ont tellement
envie que ce soit derrière nous qui font
comme si c'était derrière alors que ça
ne l'est pas mais est ce que dans la
politique du gouvernement au delà des
vaccinations au delà des traitements qui
je l'espère seront de plus en plus
efficace parce que ça nous éviterait
pour beaucoup les vaccinations et des
médicaments est ce que ce n'est pas une
réflexion à avoir
un peu sur le partage entre la
protection sanitaire absolument
nécessaire et qui ne doit pas être fait
au compte-gouttes et d'autre part leur
comment dire la vie sociale qui à un
moment
fini par être extrêmement difficile on
vous l'avait dit pour le télétravail ça
réduit les transports ça réduit les
contacts mais
télétravail aussi l'inconvénient sens
inverse de réduire les liens sociaux et
au bout de deux ans on semblait une
certaine lassitude dans l'opinion or
cette lassitude elle et elle est pré
difficile parce que par définition elle
peut conduire à des attitudes peu
prudente et donc à des contaminations
qu'est-ce que vous proposeriez vous au
gouvernement de faire en la matière et
quel type de communication le
gouvernement devrait faire je suis très
frappé je le dis et sincèrement j'arrête
là monsieur président de voir que
en 2020 il y avait des communications
tous les jours sur ce qu'il fallait
faire pas faire sur la pandémie est
qu'aujourd'hui la communication est
beaucoup plus faible on voit des clips
sincèrement
très gentil quoi mais ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'impact sur les jambes donc
est ce que là dessus il faudrait pas
modifier un peu la comité turbulences
sans inquiéter les gens en les rassurant
même lorsqu'il le faut surtout - et mais
en même temps leur demandant de faire un
effort
jean michel arnaud
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président merci chacun
des intervenants pour leur exposer je
jouerai de trois questions très rapide
pour laisser le temps à chacune et
chacun de s'exprimer vous avez insisté
dans une partie d'autres exposés sur
l'émergence de médicaments je croisais
même dit de nouveaux médicaments
est ce que vous pourriez être en
situation d'être un peu plus précis à la
fois sur la manière dont les personnes
exposées au virus
pourrait considérer qu'il faut attendre
le médicament plutôt de passer par le
vaccin puisqu'on a des solutions à terme
qui peuvent être le médicament est un
pas que ça peut avoir sur la dynamique
globale de l'épidémie au vu finalement
une partie certes
non majoritaire de la population qui est
clairement contre le vaccin donc moi
pour votre appréciation sur ce sujet
vous avez également insisté sur le fait
qu'il fallait poursuivre je reprends
votre formule je crois que c'est madame
lacombe qui l'avait dit qu'il faut
poursuivre l'effort de recherche
notamment sur le séquençage est ce que
vous avez à ce jour des difficultés des
demandes des questions de moyens alors
aux humains et financiers qui se pose
pour poursuivre cet effort de recherche
et est ce que cet effort de recherche
s'il est si les réels et les puissants
ne s'est pas au détriment d'autres
formes de recherche qui sont des
pathologies autres qui progresse ou qui
sont laissés en ce sens second grand
médiatique
extrêmement impacté par effet domino
dans la crise
voilà en substance les deux questions
rapides que je voulais vous poser vous
avez vu est également le fait que je
crois que si vous madame
[Musique]
finalement on avait une vague par par
saison
donc puisqu'on est la quatrième vague
est ce que finalement en tenant des
propos de cette nature là où on le
disant ainsi en laisse pas entendre à
une partie de la population finalement
tout ça est assez régulier que si on
compare à l'impact de la grippe
saisonnière on peut on peut on peut
relativiser finalement l'intérêt de
serre vaccinés ou d'être attentif à
l'évolution de la maladie
merci laurence cohen
merci moi aussi deux trois questions
assez rapide parce qu'en fait mes
collègues jean-michel arnaud et roger
karoutchi ont posé des questions qui a
les dents dans le même sens - je redis
par rapport aux doses suffisantes pour
le rappelle c'est à dire la troisième
vaccination un exemple très concret
prise de rendez vous hier pour une
personne de 91 ans pas du tout aux
sollicité par son médecin traitant pas
du tout encouragé et bien donc il ya un
an nous étions le 29 novembre son rendez
vous c'est le 23 décembre donc si vous
voulez il ya quand même un petit
problème là est encore sous réserve que
enfin le rendez vous a été pris mais
c'était sous réserve d'avoir
effectivement les deux donc c'est mama
question deuxième deuxième élément ça a
été demandé par jean michel arnaud c'est
sur le séquençage peut-être mieux
comprendre en quoi finalement le
séquençage peut aider ou au progrès que
ce soit en termes de vaccination ou de
traitement et effectivement si la au
niveau de la recherche notamment en
france il ya suffisamment de moyens
humains et financiers pour la mener pour
la mener à bien et la troisième question
c'est que je suis un peu interrogatif
sur le fait qu' on a vu lors des vagues
successives des personnes interrogées
notamment dans les médias qui se sont
propulsés comme étant des experts et qui
ont quand même donné des
va dire des indications assez
contradictoire et ça trouble beaucoup
l'opinion publique parce que du coup on
ne sait plus qui est qui croient et
notamment là il ya quand même quelques
préconisations qui sont très
contradictoires en termes des protocoles
à adopter au niveau des écoles sur les
fermetures de classes ou pas sur la
distanciation des enfants ou pas enfin
il ya des choses qui sont un petit peu
qu'ils ne paraissent pas logique et qui
font qu'à partir c'est pas logique c'est
mal suivis et et c'est pas du tout
compris donc est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
quelques éléments un peu j'allais dire
cadran pour pouvoir aider de notre coq
et merci beaucoup
alors je crois bien milian poumirol
encore
oui merci je dirais contre les questions
qui ont déjà été posés moi je voulais
revenir ce caractère pandémique que vous
avez évoquées et sur la nécessité
effectivement autant que l'afrique
restera 10 % de vaccination en hausse
grandes chances de voir le mettant au
mikron et puis on arrivera comme ça
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de la jab et
qu'elle est est ce qu'il y a vraiment
une volonté au niveau de l' oms au
niveau européen de faire vraiment
quelque chose pour cette vaccination
pour les pays en voie de développement
où se nouent vcomment visera les appeler
on a parlé de problèmes de la levée des
brevets mais puisque ça je crois que
c'est la capacité à produire localement
qui est difficile donc ça ne peut être
que sinon les pays riches on apporte
notre notre accent donc ce qui est ce
qu'il ya une vraie volonté
internationale là dessus parce que sinon
je crois qu'on arrive à la 8e 9e 10e
vague et ses thèmes qu'on aura des
foyers comme ça où tout les variantes de
se développer
jean luc fichet
une question assez précises qui m'a été
posée c'est pour ça que la transmet ici
quelle attitude adopter les femmes
enceintes par rapport à la vaccination
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
autour de ça je peux faire vacciner je
me fais pas vacciner qu'est ce qui
serait le mieux c'est une autre question
qui contiendrait les fêtes de fin
d'année mais je crois qu'elle n'est pas
simple je pense que je la
tiens tu es tu crois que jean luc fichet
veut savoir si papy et mamie devons
aller dans la cuisine pour manger le
chien c'est ça la question katia
pourceaux poli une question puisque les
autres ont déjà été posées également moi
je
on a on a beaucoup d'informations
contradictoires et je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment une communication il y
à des personnes qui ont fait l'écho vide
six mois après ils ont fait donc une
dose là on leur demande de faire une
troisième dose et ces gens me disent
qu'ils font des tests sérologiques et
qu'ils ont mille deux cent mille quatre
cents 2000 anticorps donc d'un médecin à
l'autre à moi je le tour d'un médecin à
l'autre on ne vous dit pas la même chose
certains médecins vous dise il faut
faire la troisième dose d'entre médecin
vous dise non il ne faut pas la faire
tout de suite il faut attendre que vos
anticorps diminue donc finalement on
n'essaie plus du tout sur quel pied
danser et ces gens vous interroge donc
tous les jours je vous remercie et on
termine le tour de table avec catherine
de roche pour la question bonus oui ça
rejoint un peu l'idée de cathy apourceau
poly on voit aussi qu on devrait faire
une troisième doses d'un vaccin
différent
je n'ai pas la réponse mais pas la
réponse et puis au milieu de tout ça
j'allais dire avec des dés finalement
des personnes vaccinées qui qui font la
maladie certes atténuer mais quid du
passani terre quel est votre avis sur
l'efficacité du passé
et leur mange ici et pardon à rené paul
savary j'ai je n'avais pas vu c'est pas
grave non simplement 10% de vacciner en
afrique on se pose la question
maintenant qu'il ya des progrès
médicamenteux est-ce qu'il faut
concentrer ses efforts à les vacciner ou
bien est-ce qu'il faut concentrer ses
efforts à leur fournir des médicaments
alors voilà vous avez une liste
impressionnante de questions qui veut
commencer dominés que saviola aller sur
les enfants oui effectivement aux
etats-unis à plus de 3 millions
d'enfants qui ont déjà reçu la
vaccination pour l'instant ma
connaissance que c'était sûrement le cas
la semaine dernière
et puis aucun cas de myocardite déclaré
puisque c'est fait partie des effets
indésirables pour pouvait craindre
et donc pour l'instant on n'a pas vu de
signe au nouveau émergé non plus de
cette exposition assez large je pense
que c'est un élément important pour
asseoir les décisions qui vont être
prises sur la vaccination des enfants
parce que c'est sûr que dans les sec
avait été conduit en tout cas pour le
vexin faciale le nombre d'enfants
exposés ne permet pas de garantir
absolument un risque très faible
avec 3 millions d'exposer et voit encore
attendre d'avoir un peu le retour des
données là on va avoir des données
solides qui je pense vont transformer la
façon dont on peut évaluer le risque une
chose aussi que je voulais dire c'est
qu'il ya le ecdc a mis en ligne hier sur
ocre et print qui est soumis sur une
étude qu'ils ont fait à l'heure dans 10
pays d'europe il ya pas la france mais à
des pays comme l'italie l'espagne trois
pays qui sont pas extraordinairement
différents et dans lequel il montre que
en fait le la proportion parmi les cas
symptomatiques chez les enfants la
proportion de spécialisée est assez
faible mais que en revanche même si le
fait d'avoir des comorbidités un facteur
de risque 83% des enfants qui ont été
hospitalisés n'avaient aucun facteur de
risque donc les gens qui pensent que
c'est pas grave parce que leur enfant
n'a pas de facteur de risque voyez c'est
pas un centime c'est pas un sentiment
qui est basée sur les données c'est
vraiment donc après c'est une façon
considérer les choses est ce qu'on se
considère que c'est grave ou que c'est
pas grave on voit bien que dans la
communauté scientifique y compris à la
société française de pédiatrie à des
gens qui pensent que c'est pas grave
mais d'autres sociétés de pédiatrie de
par le monde trouve que c'est grave et
que du coup pouce à la vaccination ont
des positions relativement différente
après toujours sur les l'école là je
pense que comme toujours tout dépend de
quel est l'objectif que l'on se fixe par
rapport aux mesures
c'est l'objectif est bien sûr c'est un
objectif que de dire qu'on veut
minimiser ou qu'on veut laisser les
écoles ouvertes et assurer au maximum la
continuité et d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'on interprète les
mesures qui ont été prises c'est que là
on commençait à avoir une augmentation
exponentielle du nombre de classes
fermées et donc du coup voilà on se dit
ben non on va changer la règle pour pas
que les classes fermées mais ça veut pas
dire que les gens sont là parce que
quand même un certain nombre d'enfants
qui sont exclues pour lequel pour eux
c'est pas si facile comment fait le
professeur des écoles si là je suis pas
dix enfants qui sont en
qui sont chez eux et puis les autres qui
sont là et comment il fait pour gérer
les deux voiliers la continuité c'est
pas si évident que ça et moi
personnellement vous avez compris que
moi je pense que je ne vois aucune bonne
raison pour qu'un enfant doivent aller à
l'hôpital quoi si on pouvait l'éviter à
condition que ce soit pas un coup
peut-être totalement démesurée bien
entendu donc voila moi c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'avais signé des tribunes
plaidant pour con qu'on minimise le
risque à l'école pas du tout pour qu'on
ferme les écoles mal là mais au contact
qu'on essaie de faire au maximum pour
qu'il y ait la moindre circulation
possible du virus à l'école et voilà
c'est ça qui justifient au fond les
points qui est mis en avant dans mon
intervention
alors pour juste un petit mot sur la
vaccination
la vaccination en fait le problème
n'est pas qu'un nombre de doses en
france je n'y a pas de problème de doses
et un problème de réorganisation du
système puisque les centres de
vaccination étaient en train de fermer
et puis là il faut les rouvrir folle et
réorganiser il faut voir qu'on voit
c'est pas si facile que ça de d'aller
dans un sens puis dans l'autre de façon
extrêmement rapide donc je pense que
c'est ça qui est exclu et aussi le fait
que finalement on est passé de ses
seulement chez les plus de 65 ans puis
au louvre qui ont dit 40 en plus en fait
on dit tout le monde du jour au
lendemain voilà des gens ont eu lieu un
peu de mal à s'organiser je pense que ce
qui explique les délais la prise de
rendez-vous et y compris pour une
situation si j'ai compris que vous avez
décrite de thé très très importante
qu'est il faut aussi primo vexé mais ce
qu'on jamais été vacciné si c'est
possible les gens à risque en
particulier et on sait qu'il y en a un
certain nombre parce que c'est eux qui
sont les plus à risque a bien sûr si
vous avez été vaccinées il ya cinq mois
on est pas aussi bien protégés que si
vous aviez été vaccinées ya trois mois
vous êtes quand même mieux protéger
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais reçu de
vaccination ou jamais fait la queue vie
d'un donc voilà je pense qu'il faut
aussi un site est toujours sur le aller
vers aller vers les gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés alors que c'est pas par
opposition ce cas décrit guérin tout à
l'heure et du coup oui il ya eu des
hésitations au départ ce qui fait que le
message n'a peut-être pas est très clair
mais il est clair que la vaccination des
femmes enceintes est encouragée et voilà
je peux dire que y compris à titre
individuel c'est absolument ce que j'ai
conseillé à mme agnès quand elle m'a
posé la question
parce que les femmes enceintes sont plus
à risque de formes graves et aussi ça
peut rejaillir sur sur le sur le foetus
est donc il là il ya clairement une
indication avec un bénéfice individuel
pour les femmes enceintes
et si je peux dire alors le
mesurer le test des anticorps à part
pour se dire qu'on en a plus que le
voisin et dépenser de l'argent ça ne
sert à rien
ça en fait vous pourriez avoir un taux
un peu plus bas mais que notre système
réagissent quand vous allez très exposés
parce qu'il n'ya pas que les anticorps
il ya aussi le fait que vous avez appris
à vos cellules b à en faire et qu'elles
en font beaucoup plus rapidement quand
elles ont appris que si elle n'avait
jamais appris et est donc et donc voilà
il n'y a pas de démonstration bien clair
qu'un taux d'anticorps à un moment donné
près 10 quand vous allez répondre donc
voilà c'est pour dépenser de l'argent
dans la recherche on fait ça mais dans
la recherche parce qu'on cherche à
comprendre on a envie de savoir on a
envie de savoir s'il ya une corrélation
entre ce taux est et 1 et un niveau de
protection ce jeu qu'on ne sait pas au
jour d'aujourd'hui mais dans la vie
quotidienne pour le pékin moyen voilà
voilà d'ailleurs ne le fait pour aucun
vaccin
des protocoles de rappel n'induisent pas
de mesure du taux d'anticorps avant la
réalisation d'une dose de rappel sur
aucun vaccin est peut-être un nom mais
papa sur le détail des médicaments mais
un mot sur la stratégie parce que ça
c'est justement ce sur quoi je travaille
dans le le projet européen là que j'ai
sur la conduite c'est
ce à quoi on réfléchit sur les
traitements une fois qu'on en aura
quelques uns de valider c'est peut-être
de faire des combinaisons parce que
parce qu'on sait que ça on a vu dans
d'autres maladies infectieuses que
c'était mieux de faire des combinaisons
que d'avoir un seul traitement et
peut-être qu'ici pas exactement la même
chose c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer
aussi à faire des recherches sur
internet dans ce qu'on a pour l'instant
faut bien voir que le le vaccin
coûte moins cher et à une meilleure
efficacité
que les traitements que l'on a à l'heure
actuelle les anticorps c'est hors de
prix le les antiviraux on a l'impression
que la curva être alentours de 6 à 700
euros c'est beaucoup plus cher que le
vaccin pour des niveaux d'efficacité
pour l'instant qu'ils ne sont pas aussi
bon sur les firmes et gran de le que que
le vaccin donc bien sûr que c'est utile
parce qu'il y aura toujours des gens il
ya toujours des gens qui m'aiment
vacciner vos montres harris etc c'est
absolument très important qu'on en est
mais il n'y a pas photo entre ce qu'est
ce qu'il faut favoriser ça vexe et en
afrique le problème n'est pas seulement
un nombre de doses en parts égales par
exemple en afrique du sud dans d'autres
pays oui bien sûr il ya un problème de
nombre d'avoir des doses disponibles
mais c'est aussi un problème
d'organisation
comment on fait on a bien vu chez nous
que ça n'a pas été si facile à mettre en
oeuvre de comment on fait pour vacciner
les gens comment on fait pour vacciner
les gens dans un pays africain c'est pas
si facile et aussi il faut pas croire il
ya aussi une hésitation actional dans
ces pays là et donc il ya des aspects
voiliers de logistique et
d'anthropologie extrêmement important
aussi à prendre en compte bien sûr il
faut ces questions ne se pressent pas si
ya pas de doses mais c'est pas seulement
le problème des doses qui compte c'est
aussi les autres aspects je m'arrête
merci
karen lacombe
oui mais je les prends le relai
dominique sur les quelques points
qu'elle n'a pas abordé donc en
particulier peut-être ce qui touche au
traitement puis après je vous dirai un
mot sur au delà du dauphin leur
équilibre entre la protection sanitaire
et le maintien d'une vie sociale et vous
donnerai mon opinion avec un exemple
européen un ex européen à côté de leur
offre je vais vous reparler du royaume
uni
le donc en ce qui concerne l'efficacité
du môle du pire à vire
vous m'aviez demandé alors en fait vous
savez ce qui est très compliqué avec
c'est logique industrielle c'est d'avoir
accès aux données
publiées dans des journaux revues par
les pairs c'est à dire avec un regard
critique scientifique qui permet de
remettre les choses à leur place alors
juste place dans l'environnement global
sans avoir de pression de qui que ce
soit et en particulier de l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour l'instant on nous a
demandé de nous prononcer sur des
données issues de communiqués de presse
ça rend toujours les données très
parcellaires et pour moi impossible à
analyser évidemment nous ne sommes pas
des experts de la fbf je ne suis pas une
experte de la chasse qui eux ont eu ou
vont avoir
accès à ces données et vont se prononcer
en connaissance de cause donc pour
l'instant c'est difficile de dire si ces
traitements sont efficaces et si on va
les utiliser à grande échelle en tant
que scientifique on espère que dès que
des traitements antiviraux puisse
changer la donne dans la prise en charge
ambulatoire c'est-à-dire en dehors de
l'hôpital de l'infection donc je pense
qu'il faut attendre que les experts de
la has alors de l'allier ce soir pour
certaines de ses molécules et puis dans
un dans un très proche avenir de la
chasse et on peut avoir confiance en eux
pour nous montrer voilà si ces molécules
sont efficaces ou pas
ensuite vous aviez donc peut-être une
question sur le je vais peut-être laissé
à yazd anc est quand même directeur de
la mrc milieu des questions sur la
recherche et sur l'investissement
le retard potentiel qu'on a pu avoir
surtout en matière de séquençage mais ça
on n'y a eu un gros effort mais après
paul pour le reste donc il y répondra
moi je peux vous dire un peu ce qu'il en
est de la question que vous nous avez
posé et qui pour moi est effectivement
fondamental c'est
la liberté individuelle de décider pour
soi et le respect d'une vie aux
collectivités
c'est vrai que ce qui est extrêmement
important dans des épisodes majeurs
comme la pandémie de la pandémie que
l'on vit c'est d'avoir un équilibre
entre la protection des autres et notre
liberté individuelle
et mettre le curseur un endroit ou un
autre aura toujours des mécontents
personne qui vous dire on est en
dictature sanitaires et 2 qui vous
diront on est en danger
quand on regarde l'option qui a été
prise au royaume uni où est d'ailleurs
nos collègues les membres du
gouvernement au royaume uni le répète
assez souvent nous on laisse le virer
circuler et on est stable en termes
d'hospitalisation
et de et d'impact sur le système
sanitaire mais à quel prix à quel prix
la mortalité en angleterre est plus
élevé qu'en france est continuellement
plus élevé avec un impact sur le système
de soins le système hospitalier qui est
très important avec le nhs qui est le
l'hôpital public est constamment sous
tension avec des listes d'attentes très
important pour avoir accès à une prise
en charge tendent à pour des opérations
relativement bénigne et autres donc
effectivement ils ont pris cette option
là alors ils l'ont pris jusqu'à
maintenant vous savez qui sont en train
de revenir en arrière puisqu'on et on
remet le masque dans le métro etc donc
ils ont pris ils ont fait un pari ils
ont fait un pari à mon avis en
sacrifiant une partie la plus vulnérable
évidemment de la population mais dans
une société comme la nôtre
on doit prendre soin des plus
vulnérables d'entre nous et donc c'est
vraiment une histoire de savoir placer
le curseur au bon endroit parce qu'on
n'est pas qu'une société de gagnants qui
allons de l'avant on est une société qui
devons prendre soin les uns des autres
et je pense que dans ce contexte là on a
essayé depuis 18 mois d'avoir une
balance à mon avis qui était pas si mal
équilibré que ça et c'est aussi pour ça
que dans les mesures que j'ai proposé
j'ai essayé de mettre en avant que des
choses qui sont certes contraignante
mais voilà qui n'empêche pas vraiment
totalement les activités et tout ça
parce que je pense que si on combine
toutes ces mesures là on peut y arriver
sans avoir besoin de revenir sur des
choses qu'on a tous détestés pourrait
quitter le fait extrêmement
contraignante est extrêmement difficile
que juste rajouter un point sur les
médicaments
c'est un autre enjeu des médicaments
dont on parle outre le fait que pour
l'instant on n'a pas vu les données donc
on n'a pas la même on n'a pas les mêmes
résultats de communautés de présent
communiqué de presse ne rien comprendre
pourquoi et pour l'instant on ne
comprend pas bien c'est qu'un an je sais
qu'il faudra le donner dans les cinq
jours du début des symptômes à l'heure
actuelle en france ses environs de vie
les gens se présentent pour une paix
sert environ 2,2 jours après le début
des symptômes dans l'essai coverage qui
était laissé en mi temps
laissait un homme en ville qui a
coordonné toutes les équipes qui
voulaient faire des essais en ville
finalement mme vassal anrs les personnes
et est incluse dans l'essai en médiane
quatre jours après le début des
symptômes que ceux de la moitié moins de
quinze jours la moitié plus de quatre
jours au ps les traitements ça va si on
est au tout début des traitements non
coupable comme le menu qu'il avait ça va
si on every cinq jours des symptômes
c'est aussi pour ça que vous voyez par
rapport au vaccin on fait bien mal
avance plutôt que la de voir le tester
le voir le médecin à voir la
prescription avoir la délivrance voilà
c'est aussi ça qu'il faut prendre en
compte et le cunha entendus pour se dire
que bien sûr ces raids contributif parce
que tous ceux qui pourront la voir sera
toujours ça
mais c'est pas si voilà ça va parce donc
changer la donne que ça sauf si on se
donne les moyens de faire une
organisation très efficace pour que les
gens aient accès bien vous prévenir
voilà en général ça coûte moins cher
vous avez terminé oui je pense apprend
des choses et bien lauriad dans l'ain en
panne à eau mais merci beaucoup donc je
veux revenir sur ces quelques points
rapidement et après je compléterai bon
et je trouve que sur les enfants je
pense que c'est quand même une question
hyper difficile ça veut dire que nous on
a fait un travail pour le sénat ou au
moins de juin sur
justement les dépistages répétées des
enfants qui a été fait par l'inria colza
ou on est vraiment pour des dépistages
répétées des enfants des jeunes enfants
qui sont pas vaccinés brûle le conseil
scientifique voulait dire beaucoup voilà
alors on l'a fait au niveau de la nrf
c'est contre ces scientifiques bien sûr
a aussi souligné ça il ya des questions
autour de la faisabilité mais bon malgré
tout comme l'a dit dominique n'auront
pensent la même chose un secret il est
important de pousser ça mais
il semble qu'il ya des problèmes de
faisabilité
deuxièmement sur le vaccin moi je suis
sur un peu sur la même ligne que que ce
qu'a dit dominique et de vous l'avais
dit à peut-être d'ouvrir à ce qu'ils
sont après
exemple la société française de
pédiatrie n'est pas son avenir
la société française de l'infectiologie
et qu'elles font partie karine et moi je
vais l'avis de carina labadie mais moi
je ne suis pas complètement d'accord
donc vous voyez c'est ce que vous disiez
quoi en fait il ya certains points mais
pourquoi on est parfois on n'est pas
d'accord aussi parce que
si vous voulez
les données ne sont pas si robuste que
ça vous est ce que c'est pas toujours
aussi simple ça il faut le savoir aussi
et
du coup toutes les questions ne sont pas
non plus très facile et ça bouge dans le
temps et effectivement vous avez si vous
l'avez souligné son expertise
scientifique et cetera autant parfois
c'est n'importe quoi parfois je pense
qu'il faut accepter il faut qu'on le il
ya une incertitude autour de nos
recommandations
vous n'avez pas parlé 24 in surtout n'a
pas parlé de l'hôpital dont il n'a pas
elle qui a parlé de retard mais vous
avez posé la question de l'hôpital
je pense qu'il est important de dire que
l'hôpital il ya le problème de call to
call it vous avez entièrement raison
vous avez donné le chiffre de mille sept
cent quarante neuf de saint-dominique
sur la réanimation
mais je pense qu'actuellement nous qui
sont à l'hôpital il ya aussi un problème
de nos kourichi des zones et j'insiste
beaucoup sur le nom qu vie et je pense
que sur l'hôpital
on sait comment contenir cette vague et
c'est un peu nous avons des solutions
quelque part nous la population pour
continuer mais je pense qu'il faut
absolument
sur l'hôpital arrêter de penser à court
terme et avoir une réflexion à long
terme parce que les problèmes sont
beaucoup plus importants que le problème
de coville est vraiment il faut qu'on le
vit tous les jours et vraiment ça c'est
un problème où il faut à côté d'une
réflexion court terme pour savoir
comment gérer le problème qu vide et
tout ce qui va avec vraiment rapidement
commencer à réfléchir au long terme tout
de suite y compris nous au sein de notre
hôpital parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important sur les médicaments ça
a été dit je dis je dis rien de plus
juste
malheureusement les communiqués de
presse en plus la soul nie pas ravir y
en a un qui disait 50 % d'efficacité
puis il ya eu 30 % d'efficacité on n'a
pas les données en plus l'étude a été
fait dans des pays multiples et c'est
donc les données sont fragiles et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut qu'on soit très
prudent dans
l'interprétation mais je pense que ce
qu'a dit karine dans son introduction on
va quand même aller vers une
stratégie probablement de tester et
traiter les patients parce qu'à un
moment donné ça va être disponible et
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit je
pense que il faut surtout pas c'est un
peu de la même façon qu'on a une
stratégie d stratégie combinée de
prévention on a des stratégies combiné
aussi pour
arrêtez la maladie et je pense que
vaccins et traitements vont bien
ensemble et en fait c'est comme
n'importe quelle maladie il faut avoir
les deux et ne pas oublier les anticorps
monoclonaux malheureusement ils sont
chers difficile et c'est un choc quand
même montré des seuls qui ont montré
leur efficacité ça c'est sûr
sur les séquençages parce que vous avez
posé la question alors je voudrais vous
dire qu'en
2020 en france il ya eu 2000 séquence
à ce jour en 2021 hilali 240 2000 c'est
qu'on sache ce qu'on a multiplié par
cent le chiffre des séquençages alors
comment alors c'est santé publique
france et la mairesse où on a utilisé le
réseau des virologues au vih on a des
plateformes de séquençage et qui sans
les centre national de référence pasteur
à la ph v on a couvert l'ensemble des
territoires il ya certes encore des
progrès à faire mais malgré tout
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui marche
pas si mal que ça on a multiplié par 100
en quelques mois le nombre de séquences
on a une bonne couverture et tout n'est
pas de dire combien c'est quoi le nom si
vous faites plein de séquences mais ça
devient toujours de même endroit ça ne
sert à rien il faut qu'il y ait une
bonne décision et là vous avez par
exemple à la réunion il ya eu des
séquences ça fait partie du même réseau
deuxièmement il faut voir quand vous
avez invariance c'est quoi des
significations donc là on a mis en place
la plateforme pour essayer de voir aussi
la significativité là par exemple le il
vend un avoir la souche d'oreilles de la
réunion ils vont regarder l'impact du
vaccin sur cette souche il ya beaucoup
d'autres qui le font on peut le faire
nous mêmes après des traitements sort
donc du coup bien sûr on peut toujours
faire mieux et il faut faire mieux mais
on a quand même pas mal un progrès ces
femmes enceintes donc ça c'est une
question assez assez simple
effectivement jusqu'au mois de mars la
chaîne avait dit
les femmes de deux grossesses que
deuxième et troisième trimestre
maintenant c'est toutes les femmes
enceintes donc il n'ya pas de contre
indication pour les femmes enceintes les
tests sérologiques ils ont répondu je
vais juste vous dire moi même moi j'ai
fait un qu'ovide et j'ai fait à une dose
de vaccin j'ai probablement beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'anti corps mais
malgré tout je fais le troisième 1 12
donc pour l'instant
on ne sait pas quelle est la
significativité alors c'est un peu
contre je comprends même pour moi ces
contraintes du tiff si j'ai vingt mille
pourquoi je vais me faire vacciner mais
on ne sais pas qu'est ce que ça veut
dire donc peut-être que et donc c'est ce
que peut il et dominique pour l'instant
ces domaines de la recherche et pour
l'instant l'idée ça va peut-être changer
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
à ce qu'on dit ça peut-être changé quand
sera calé la significativité mais pour
l'instant
je lé jeu les deux phases alors sur le
pass sanitaires
même si vous l'avez dit m six mois et
nous on regrette qu'il n'y a pas eu plus
de l'application des citoyens notamment
dans
dans la lutte entre locaux vie pour
plein de choses je pense comme un des
tous le pass sanitaire a aidé et la
france a actuellement une couverture
vaccinale est important est
le fait de l'arrêter maintenant
de le pen le fait de ne pas le
reconduire peu à avoir un impact en
plein période d'augmentation de
l'incidence alors qu on a besoin que
la population adhère un certain nombre
de règles
et notamment la vaccination
le fait de faire des rappels les
modélisations montré un impact très
important sur le delta je marche je
parle même pas de
deux micros parce que je sais pas qu'est
ce qui va se passer mais sur le détail
un impact donc il est important de
poursuivre et par ailleurs les respect d
un geste et arrière donc je pense que
quand même c'est quelque chose qui a
permis que on a 17 ans portion de plus
de vacciner quand notre isolement oui
donc
alors après je suis le premier à vouloir
et par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
j'ai aussi une implication citoyenne
plus important et je pense qu'on a été
dit que ça peut aussi avoir un impact
parce que les anti vaccins vrai ils sont
très très le nom et est extrêmement
faire
alors est ce que j'ai oublié une motion
a été rowluck je ne sais pas qui a posé
la question de vaccins hétérologue
destinée à poser c'est vous qui veulent
alors alors ça si vous voulez un en gros
c'est une question de rechercher pour
d'autres stratégies vaccinales aussi
c'est que quand on fait deux de vaccins
différents la réponse est peut-être plus
élevé depuis durable
bon là maintenant tous les rappels se
font avec des vaccins à
rsa rna par contre notamment il ya des
questionnements nous trop de vaccins
sanofi et c'est peut-être de faire des
rappels hétérologue mais pour l'instant
c'est des questions de recherche
mais
il y à des hypothèses conquois ont fait
un vaccin avec un plateforme un autre
vaccin avec un autre plateforme
peut-être qu'on a une meilleure
durabilité une meilleure réponse 'action
je pense que j'ai quasiment
répondu à tous mais je reste à votre
disposition
effectivement vous avez répondu si j'ai
rien oublié à toutes les questions rené
paul savary juste une question pendant
que les tiens monsieur par rapport aux
anticorps actuellement est remontée du
terrain que un certain nombre
effectivement de médecins ce qui ennuie
un kobe qui ont un taux d'anticorps 10
vous n'avez pas besoin de du rappel or
ils n'ont pas le fassent vacciner
au motoriste sur est obligatoire donc il
se pose un vrai problème et il semble
que vraiment là la doctrine way la
doctrine
gouvernementale soit de dire il faut
quelle que soit la situation faire la
leur appel alors est ce qu a été mis
dans les consignes d'éléments dgs urgent
et compagnie conçoit tous donc ils
mettent bien que pour simplifier que
vous ayez fait vaccin la première le
vide par l'ong s'est donc il faut quand
même faire rappel vous nous dites
scientifiquement c'est pas prouvé qu'il
faut quand même être fait c'est pas
prouvée alors
j'ai ce que vous dites est vrai dans le
sens qu'il ya des médecins généralistes
qui commence à faire des sérologies j'ai
fait la semaine dernière une
intervention chez autres frais des
médecins généralistes de senlis ça c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir de savoir
qui est en fait restée vive et ils m'ont
dit oui nous on fait le problème c'est
que on ne sait pas du tout quand vous
trouvez 18000 15000 20500 on sais pas
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vous voyez il
ya même des gens qui en fait des
institutions après il sait d'histoire de
chasse 1 parce qu'on ne sait pas mais
j'ai des histoires autour de moi dans
les hôpitaux avec des gens qui ont des
taux d'anticorps élevé si on fait une
infection sévère donc on le sait pas
donc dans le doute pour le moment il
faut pas tenir compte de la sérologie
après je vous dis pas que dans trois
mois quand le recherche on avance et on
va pas changer
catherine leroy pour compléter cette
question parce que moi j'avais interrogé
la présidente de la has ayant été
sollicitée par quelqu'un qui me dit en
fait c'est un coût plus elle convie tous
les deux testé plusieurs mois après un
été quasiment zéro en anticorps et et
elle avait un taux d'anticorps élevé et
10ème je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir la dose
de vaccin or lâchait semaine c'est
exactement ce que vous dites en disant
faites quand il ya un dosage importante
c'est pas ce qui protège réellement et
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux dans ces
conditions faire le vaccin parce qu'on
ne sait pas d'un même si à des anticorps
élevé s qui protège vraiment de la copie
ça s'est il ya des recherches en cours
là dessus il ya des recherches en cours
telle fin septembre oui il ya des
recherches en cours mais pour l'instant
on n'a pas de réponse on dit qu'il n'ya
pas de corps et la de protection ça veut
dire qu'on sait pas à partir de quel
taux il ya une vraie protection et elle
me disait peut-être même que parce que
la personne avait été n'avait plus de
tests positifs terme et avait des signes
encore de covile disaient certains ont
vu des cas les signes disparaître
justement par la vaccination
oui alors ça aussi c'est là aussi il ya
beaucoup de discussions et un artisan et
cher autour de ça mais moins sourds même
l'impact de kobe dons de vaccins sur le
colis de long là aussi pour l'instant
sincèrement je pense que c'est de la
recherche et qu' il faut pas trop
s'avancer parce qu'on ne sait pas et
quand elle ne s'est pas cette crise nous
a appris que de dire qu'on ne sait pas
bien
[Musique]
sûr c'est entièrement d'accord
ouais
bien écoutez donc mais merci à domenico
celi olala professeur lacombe et au
professeur yazdanpanah pour leurs
nombreuses réponses aux nombreuses
questions qui ont été posées demain
matin la commission des affaires
sociales auditionnera la directrice de
la rsm sources notamment la thématique
des médicaments anti kovy dès mercredi
mais la pharmacovigilance des vaccins et
mercredi 8 l'auditionnera le professeur
d'être fassi président du conseil
scientifique et la mission d'information
qu'ovide elle va poursuivre ses travaux
merci à tout merci à tous encore merci à
nos intervenants et on va arrêter là
cette réunion merci